I imagine it has to come as a surprise
when James comes to you and tells you he
wants you to play Jake and iteri's
daughter in this movie so what would you
say is the biggest difference between
your first impression of Kiri when he
first pitched the role to you and who
she turned out to be as you dug into her
for the Finish film well in fact we had
lunch uh Jim and I in LA in 2010 and we
just started talking about
maybe a girl that was related somehow to
Grace but we didn't really know how uh
who was more comfortable in the forest
with the creatures and with the Flora
and Fauna than she was with people and
that she would be around 13 or 14 and
that she would not be a fighter so we we
talked about all these things
but I was absolutely amazed when I he
sent me the script and he had you know
elaborated on all these different things
and especially the relationship with
spider was not something we talked about
that she would have this best friend you
know and I had friends like this because
I was this tone when I was 11. and I
used to sometimes see me with my best
friend like walking by a shop window
because I live in New York and I'd go oh
I'm so much taller and so when you see
the movie and you see that here is like
seven feet tall and Jack is uh you know
spiders like I don't know comparatively
much shorter and we don't see that I
don't see that he's human he doesn't see
that I'm Navi maybe he'd like to be Navi
um so I love that friendship and I think
it's an important relationship for for
the The Saga I enjoyed that connection
quite a bit
um there is obviously a connection to
Grace as well and even though Kiri
didn't get to grow up with Grace in her
life are there any particular qualities
of Graces that you thought were
important to infusing Kiri so that we
could feel the connection in addition to
just hearing that it's there I think
that she does spend time in the lab uh
and and with uh Grace's tapes
um it's uh you know natiri is a
wonderful mother but I think she has a
strong connection with Grace and gets as
much out of those videos as anyone
possibly could I think she shares the
same joy in the nature of Pandora and
the same curiosity and the same she's
much more I think instinctive than Grace
was because Grace was sort of cut in
half between the intellectual scientists
that had to do stuff at base and this
free spirit who's out who loved who
loved the culture and the people
um so you know she's sort of the best of
Grace without the smoking
I know you can't give me this answer but
I'm just curious if you know it do you
know the truth of curious conception
no okay I was just curious all right
I'll wrap with this one because I caught
a quote that you had said about working
with uh James again and you said he
always asks you is there something we
haven't tried that you would like to do
so can you give me an example of a
creative swing that was important for
you to take because he asked you that
question well for one thing when I saw
the sketches of Carrie
she was this perfect girl with a band in
her hair and very composed very neat
very natieri-like and I said to Jim
I said I don't think most 13 14 year old
girls feel like that look like that
um I don't think she
I don't think Kerry could dream of being
like natiri who's so powerful who's so
beautiful who's so perfect she doesn't
feel perfect she feels like I'm good
with spider I'm good in the forest but
the rest of it you know she's like
trying to figure out who she is who her
father is how she belongs in this world
why she feels so different from other
people and
um and so I think that um I I think I
wanted her physical being to reflect
this chaos and this sort of see-saw of
emotions that she felt from great joy to
Great feelings of Injustice and you know
all those things you feel when you're
14. I want to learn so much more about
her right now congratulations